listen to uh or actually go and witness
a minute silence in the commons
five three four
before i call the prime minister
it is with the greatest sadness
that i rise to say a few words in
tribute to her late majesty queen
lisbeth
almost all of us in the house have
experienced no other monarch this
country's thrill but her late majesty
there are indeed only a score or so
members in this house who have already
been born
let alone who can recall the time when
she wasn't the queen
she is wedding our minds with the crone
and all it stands for
after accession
in february 1952 she first came to the
palace of westminster to open the
session of parliament in november 1952
when winston churchill was the prime
minister
and speaker william morrison was in the
chair almost 70 years ago
57 complete sessions of parliament have
passed since then and as she was here to
open all but three of them as
parliamentarians we have celebrated with
her for silver
golden
diamond jubilees and of course
marked her platinum jubilee this year
in which the lamp standards have been
unveiled in new palace yard
in this place her reign
saw 10 different speakers occupied the
chair during her reign there were 18
general elections and i'm sure
the prime minister will remind of us how
many of our predecessors she welcomed to
and always i am sure with quiet wisdom
as the longest-serving monarch this
country is known
she would have been assured
of a notable entry in our history books
even were it not for
the magnificent in which she undertook
the role as queen but for a magnificent
service
and what a service that entailed
not just as head of the nation
but head of the commonwealth
head of the armed forces and supreme
governor of the church of england
over a reign
she has seen unprecedented
social
cultural technological change
through it all
she was the most conscientious and
dutiful of monarchs
but while she understood the inescapable
nature of duty which sometimes must have
weighed upon her heavily
she also delighted in carrying it out
for she was the most devoted monk
as well as queen she was a wife a mother
a grandmother and great-grandmother
roles she carried out with the same
sense of vocation as well as human
kindness as the role of queen
her life
without unhappiness and troubles but her
memories of her will be filled with that
image of a gently smiling dedication
that showed throughout her life
indeed
while this is a time of very
considerable sadness those memories of a
noble gracious lady who devoted her life
to a family the united kingdom and those
nations around the world whom she served
as queen will bring us some consolation
and joy
my deepest sympathies
are with his majesty the king
and other members of the royal family to
whom i commend all our
sincere condolences and support at this
very very sad time
order
we are meeting today for tributes to her
late majesty queen elizabeth
i would like to inform the house that we
will sit today until approximately
10 p.m for tributes at approximately six
o'clock the house will be suspended
while his majesty the king makes his
broadcast the nation
members presence will be able to watch
the broadcast on screens in the chamber
we will then resume our proceedings to
continue with tributes
the house
will then sit again tomorrow at one
o'clock
the first business will be all taking
for a small number of senior members
members to be invited to take the or
tomorrow are being contacted by my
office all other members will have an
opportunity to take the oath when the
house returns
after all taking tomorrow tributes will
be continued the house is expected to
sit till approximately 10 p.m
the house is not expected to sit on
sunday